[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal
wieder ein grundrezept von mir und zwar
machen wir leckeren pizzateig ich mache
meinen immer gerne mit frischhefe und er
gelingt auch immer und wenn ihr sehen
wollt wie ich ihn zubereitet dann bleibt
jetzt einfach dran und hier seht ihr
alles was wir benötigen das sind einmal
500 gramm mehl 2 180 milliliter
lauwarmes wasser
drei esslöffel olivenöl 1 halben würfel
frischhefe einen halben teelöffel zucker
eine messerspitze pfeffer sowie einen
gestrichenen teelöffel salz
als erstes zerbröseln ich die hefe grob
in meine ausreichend große schüssel und
gäbe dann den zucker mit hinzu den
zucker schmeckt man später nicht raus
den brauchen wir aber weil das den
nährstoff für die hefe ist außerdem
brauchen wir auch ganz dringend
lauwarmes wasser nicht zu heiß und auch
nicht zu kaltes und die drei zutaten
werden jetzt erst mal miteinander
verrührt
sobald die hefe komplett aufgelöst wurde
lasse mir das ganze zehn minuten stehen
und geben anschließend das olivenöl mit
hinzu anschließend kommt das mehl mit
hinzu ein teil des mehls tue ich
allerdings zur seite denn ich kann
später immer noch schauen ob ich das
negative oder nicht dann noch salzen und
pfeffern und anschließend frühere ich
das ganze mit einem schneebesen und wenn
ich merke dass es mit dem nicht mehr
weiter geht dann mache ich mit den
händen weiter
[Musik]
mit euren händen habt ihr dann ein
besseres gefühl dann wisst ihr ob noch
mehr mail hinzukommen muss oder nicht
meistens sind sie jedoch höchstens 500
gramm
sobald dann alles zu einer geschmeidigen
teig kugel verknetet wurde nehme ich mir
ein wenig olivenöl in die hände und
treiber sieht damit ein
und dann könnte ich das ganze noch mal
drei bis fünf minuten lang
[Musik]
und am allerbesten funktioniert das auf
der arbeitsfläche
ich habe den teig insgesamt zehn minuten
lang geknetet zwei minuten anfangs ruhig
das mit hinzu gegeben habe und hier im
bild das waren insgesamt fünf minuten
ich finde je länger man den teig knetet
desto besser und geschmeidiger wird er
damit der teig jetzt nochmal in ruhe
aufgehen kann wie sie zurück in die
schüssel gelegt allerdings solltet ihr
die schlüssel vorher beim ihren damit
auch nichts dran kleben bleibt
jetzt muss die schüssel nur noch mit
einem küchentuch abgedeckt werden und
wie lassen sich 30 minuten lang gehen
hier seht ihr das ergebnis der teig ist
schön aufgegangen und erkennt
weiterverarbeitet werden
entweder packt jetzt aus dem gesamten
tag ein blech pizza oder ihr schneidet
den teig in zwei und machte daraus zwei
runde pizzen
[Musik]
um den teig auszurollen am besten auf
die arbeitsfläche ein wenig mehr geben
dann lässt er sich wunderbar auch
ausbreiten und dann könnt ihr das ganze
so wie ihr möchtet formen und in den
backofen schieben
[Musik]
der tag lässt sich schön verarbeiten
muss auch nicht noch mal gehen ihr könnt
ihn ausrollen belegen und dann im ofen
backen
[Musik]
falls ihr sehen möchte was aus meinem
pizzateig geworden ist dann schaut doch
mal auf den link in der infobox da habe
ich nämlich meine spezial pizza und wenn
euch das video gefallen hat dann lass
mir doch gerne ein abo da bis zum
nächsten mal auf welches kitchen
[Musik]